[Music]
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stay your life on right
this is more ultimate food on a budget
vegetables are such an asset in the
kitchen healthy fantastically fresh and
Incredibly versatile and pound for pound
they're so much cheaper than fish or
meat just make sure you give them plenty
of attitude
my first recipe is so quick and easy but
seriously impressive and deceptively
cheap
homemade gnocchi making your gnocchi is
so simple to do yet the results are
absolutely stunning and it's a great way
of using up leftover baked potatoes
you can make gnocchi just with flour and
eggs however the potato gives it a nice
light sort of creamy fluffy texture
let's cut them in half take a spoon
and scoop the inside of those potatoes
I'm using leftover baked potatoes but
this really works as well with leftover
ball potatoes two choices you can get a
fork and sort of mash the potato and get
it nice and light and fluffy or
this little Gadget it's called a ricer I
suppose it's a posh word
for a potato masher just squeeze gently
you can see how nice and light it is
almost like fluffy little strands of
potato
you can do this when the potatoes are
hot it'll go through the rice so much
quicker
just slice that off there
now
a nice spoon avocado in a little touch
of salt and pepper it's really important
to season the mixture as we go along
otherwise the gnocchi becomes really
Bland flour over the ricotta see it says
no lumps
one delicious egg give that a little
whisk
now make a little well in the center you
want a nice soft pliable ball of dough
give that a really good mix
get some time flowers in there
and this time is light fragrant it's
just a really nice herb and with the
ricotta
it's brilliant just pick the little tips
the thyme flowers
next flower your hands generously and
knead the mixture into a dough
fold in and push and basically what it's
doing is getting nice and smooth as it
starts to get a little bit wet
just that and it will touch or flower
but we want something really nice and
soft and I don't overwork it stops the
knocking from expanding when it hits the
pan
that's exactly what I want a nice sort
of soft fragrant ball cut the ball in
half lightly flour
the hands and just roll it gently just
think of a big long cigar
the mixture will start getting a little
bit sort of wetter but do not add lots
of flour
now lightly flat the knife so when you
slice the gnocchi it doesn't stick
cut the dough into bite-sized pieces
just take your finger dip it in the
flour and push down why I want my Nike
to look like a pillow and for me the
most important part there is that not
one of them are identity the same shape
water on
bring up to the boil a little touch of
olive oil in there lightly flour your
hand
lift up the gnocchi
in to the rolling boiling water
turn that pan to stop them from sticking
at the bottom and let them simmer and
they start to sort of tell you they're
cooked when they start floating get a
pan on get that nice and hot now they're
just starting to come to the top and you
can continue cooking them like that I
like blanching in the water take them
out and then frying them to say to the
gnocchi heat olive oil in a frying pan
gently lift up and look they've doubled
in size
drain it get rid of the excess water and
straight in to the hot pan
[Music]
this is where they start to take on a
completely different texture nice crisp
saute texture on the outside gnocchi
loves fresh pepper so
pepper in
and you'll see as I start turning them
I've got this really nice little sort of
Brown
color
are they almost puffing up now like
little Parcels so I want them nice and
sauteed both sides but light and creamy
in the center
Fresh Garden peas
in on the bus gives it a really nice
sort of burnwise that flavor on the end
useful
it's got a little bit of fresh thyme
over the peas and then finally I want to
lift it up fresh lemon zest the lemon
over
[Music]
smells incredible
and then finally seal the deal with a
touch of grated Parmesan cheese give you
vegetarian attitude and you'll get
amazingly elegant dishes on a budget
that are always guaranteed to impress
what more do you want from great cooking
keep to make easy to cook and absolutely
stunning
cooking great food doesn't mean you have
to spend a fortune on fancy equipment
get some Basic Essentials and you'll be
set in the kitchen saucepans I mean
basically you don't need a collection of
10. all you need really is two a medium
sized one followed by a large one a
small pan is great for sources heating
liquids or rice whereas your large pan
gives you space perfect for pastas stews
or when you're cooking in bulk which
keeps costs down
made from copper to stainless steel find
what's right for you and always get a
lid which helps heat the pan up as
quickly as possible
and the secret behind a great saucepan
is
heavier the bottom the more heat it will
conduct the thinner the bottom the more
charge you've got actually burning with
food buy the best saucepans you can
afford take good care of them and
they'll last you years saving you money
in the long run
[Music]
[Applause]
amazing recipes don't necessarily have
to include meat cooking vegetarian
dishes will reduce your food bills
without compromising on taste and flavor
here are three more recipes to satisfy
even the keenest carnivore like me that
will max out on veg and won't break the
bank
[Music]
[Applause]
starting with spicy black beans with
feta and avocado
[Music]
[Applause]
first in a pan heat olive oil add
chopped onion and Fry until soft
then finely sliced garlic and chili
add cumin
cinnamon and black beans then combined
cook together until deliciously soft
these small beans come dried or in tins
and there are great cheap ingredients to
make dishes more substantial to serve
dollop the black bean mixture on crunchy
tortillas topped with Cube ripe avocado
chopped fresh coriander and crumbled
salty feta cheese
spicy black beans with feta and avocado
a dish that's filling Frugal and tastes
fantastic
my next great veg recipe is
leaking Greer Rusty with fried eggs
[Music]
in a hot pan sweat shredded leeks along
with a knob of butter and seasoning
[Music]
next great parvoir potatoes and Greer a
hard swiss cheese with a great nutty
flavor then combine with the softened
leaves
in a pan heat oil and a little butter
spoon in the potato leek and cheese mix
cook gently until golden and crisp
underneath
then slide onto a plate
flip over and return to the pan to
finish cooking
[Music]
finally for the perfect topping fry two
eggs
and place them on top of the roster
top with fresh tarragon
[Music]
leaking gray Air Rusty with fried eggs a
simple but substantial dish that makes
the most of hearty root veg
[Music]
addition takes as much time to write on
a Blackboard as it does to cook
chickpea cumin and spinach koftas with
tahini dressing
in a blender put tin chickpeas cumin
seeds
paprika
and turmeric
and Blitz to a paste
[Music]
next roll spinach in olive oil and chop
finely then add to the chickpea mixture
sprinkling gram flour made from finely
ground chickpeas then shade golf ball
side chunks of the mixture using a spoon
and rest in the fridge when ready to
cook heat oil in a frying pan
shallow fry the koftas until golden
brown on all sides then rest them on
kitchen paper to absorb any excess oil
for an easy dipping sauce mix yogurt
with a dollar but tahini
and a squeeze of lemon
then stir in freshly chopped coriander
a mouth-watering dish that's perfect for
sharing chickpea cumin and spinach
koftas with tahini dressing
[Music]
three amazing recipes with fantastic veg
proof that even if you're cooking on a
budget you can still eat like a king
incredible
[Music]
welcome back to my ultimate cookery
course
this is how to cook amazing food on a
budget next up my guide to getting the
best ingredients for your money my
shopping Mantra is simple first rely on
your senses make sure whatever you're
buying that it looks smells and really
feels good second is to recognize that
knowledge is crucial the more you know
personally about where your ingredients
are from and how they produce the better
so don't be scared ask lots of questions
and learn
and when it comes to buying potatoes a
great ingredient if you're cooking on a
budget one green grocer who can always
spot a Dub's bud is Borough Market
royalty Fred Foster it's all about
Flavor it's all about choosing the right
variety for the right fish he's been
selling top quality veg for over 15
years and really nosy King Edwards from
his Duke of Yorks basically there's two
types of potatoes there's early season
and a main crop potato early season is
basically around about May time you
can't store them they cannot be stored
would you have to buy them and use them
within two to three days when you're
buying an early season potato you must
avoid green looking potatoes at all
costs it really is important and the way
you can tell that is if you just brush
the potato the skin comes off really
really easy and then you want you want a
yellowy or Whitey looking potato the new
season of potato is a superb potato to
use new season types include rocket Home
Guard and Maris Bard but my favorite is
the classic jersey Royal it has a
delicate sweet flavor it's packed with
vitamin C and is great in salads or
simply boiled and mixed with olive oil
and fresh mint Jersey bataya's early
crop are phenomenal look at that
um
keep the skin on it's really important
just wash it boil it it's a beautiful
beautiful potato and that's what we're
talking about we're talking about I know
it's a potato I know it's a bit sad but
we're talking about flavor
right then what is a main crop potato
it's the crop that is grown specifically
for Nine Months of the Year use when
you're looking at a main crop potato you
need to see that the eyes aren't too
large because they tend to go right
through the potato
they've got to be firm it's very very
important if a potato in any way feels a
little bit soft discarded storage wise
dark place cool place dryer place and
that will last until you eat it simple
as that both early season and main crop
potatoes come in two main types waxy and
Flowery waxy potatoes have a smooth
dense flesh and because they're low in
starch they stay firm when cooked
types include Anya and ping fur but I
love Charlotte which has an amazing
buttery taste and a great sauteed in
stews or serves whole with roast chicken
flowery potatoes have a fluffy dry
texture when cooked which makes them
great for mashing roasting or cutting
into chips types include King Edward
whose smooth creamy flesh is perfect for
potato gratins or with Rich Meats like
beef and Desiree which have an amazing
red skin and are great for bacon or as
delicious potato wedges old-fashioned
types known as Heritage potatoes are now
widely available and have fantastic
colors and distinctive tastes that are
great when you want something different
this one's called Salad blue when you
cut it you then see the most amazing
color and it's perfect it looks stunning
on the plate are really popular
it's so important when you're going out
to pick your potatoes you already know
in advance what you're going to do with
that potato so whether you're going to
put it in a salad whether it's a Masher
or a chipper or even a baking potato
each variety has a unique flavor Fred's
spot on where the new season main crop
waxy or flowery potatoes are incredibly
versatile and packed with great flavor
the perfect ingredient when you're
cooking on a budget well how much do I
love potato as well
cook them simply proper flavors
it doesn't get any better
[Music]
like all chefs for me there's nothing
better than seasonal produce at its peak
when fruit and veg is fresh in season
and fantastic you ripe I can't wait to
get back in the kitchen
to get the most out of your cooking
always use ingredients in their Prime
my next recipe is a proper British
classic that's super simple to cook and
costs next to nothing a delicious apple
crumble
crumbles are the perfect way to use
fruit when it's in season there's lots
of it about it's nice and cheap but most
importantly the fruits at its absolute
best
first off I'm going to make a really
nice light caramel panel nice and low
great two apples
[Music]
and this helps to almost sort of pure
the Apple so much quicker there's a lot
of flavor in the skin so don't worry
about peeling the fruit whether it's
pears plums peaches flavors in the skin
nice
to start the camera a couple of
tablespoons of sugar the sugar helps to
get rid of the tartness in the Apple a
touch
cinnamon that starts to make it a little
spicy open up your vanilla just scrape
out all those seeds now this just makes
it light and fragrant all those seeds in
to the Sugar We're making caramel be
patient and always swirl the dish
instead of stirring it
when the sugar goes Brown add the Apple
starts to sort of cool down the caramel
but it gives it a really nice sort of
caramelized puree apples almost
disintegrating
smells incredible
turn the gas down
slice up two apples it's a crumble
That's Got No Frills straight forward no
faffing around no peeling on the skin I
want them to sort of stand out from the
camera
apples in
now those nice thick chunks of Apple
sort of almost bedding itself into the
puree
dried cranberries gives it that nice
sort of shock in the texture
sweet
chewy I want it to sort of taste zesty
spicy so sit the lemon zest on top of
your apples and cranberry fresh lemon
juice over and that just gives that
extra acidic kick takes the Cranberries
the apples the caramel and the cinnamon
to another level turn the gas off
so that says let's concentrate on the
crumble flowering
a couple of tablespoons of Demerara
sugar sugar helps to get the topping
nice and crispy butter in
give that a nice little rub what we're
looking for is like a
breadcrumb mixture lightly season it
with a touch of cinnamon
and the dinner sugar sort of helps to
get a nice fine crumble mix and it stops
the butter from sort of melting in that
flour so that's the basic crumble mix
but I'm not finished yet muesli
two-thirds crumble it's one third muesli
mix that in if you haven't got muesli
then crunchy granola works brilliantly
too lovely
now start off in the center
and work your way around
I want the crispiness on the top
the puree on the bottom of the caramel
and then the texture in the center a
good tip
and the gas back on I want it bubbling
but before it goes in the oven because
then you just got to cook the top so as
soon as you see that caramel starting to
Bubble down the side in she goes let's
go
[Music]
bake it 200 degrees Celsius for 12 to 14
minutes until golden brown
smells amazing
beautiful
still bubbling
and look at it a delicious but very
simple crumble with apples at their
absolute best beautiful
[Music]
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips
first up cooking pasta a great budget
basic to keep in the cupboard it can be
easily undercooked or overcooked here's
how to do it properly first water in
nice large pan to make sure the pest has
got sufficient room to cook evenly
nicely seasoned absolutely crucial olive
oil in that stops the pasta from
sticking together bring it up to the
ball
that's the rolling boil the secret there
it stops the pasta from sticking
together and it gently rolls it around
now this is Angel pasta nice thin pasta
takes three and a half to four minutes
so into the pan as it hits the water it
melts and then you turn it round tongs
as that starts to melt gently twist that
into the pan bring it back up to the
boil if you're bad at timing then set a
timer
beautiful
to test it lift a little strand
you can actually feed it with your
fingers it's still nice and firm
Al Dente not a bite not a strong bite
but just really nice and firm inside
definitely not crunchy and then into a
colander drain the pasta
in
a light seasoning salt
and pepper
a tablespoon
of olive oil
mix that through
that stops IT from sticking together
and look there you go beautiful pasta al
dente
cooked perfectly
a tip for making the most of spare bread
Blitz leftovers into breadcrumbs great
for stuffing or crab cakes or cut into
chunks and freeze for perfect croutons
on demand or simply tear and use in a
delicious rustic salad
dried pulses like chickpeas or lentils
are great for Soups and stews and cost
pennies but don't season them until the
end of the cooking or the salt makes
them go tough
[Music]
perfect ball potatoes always start them
off in cold water and never boiling
water this way by the time the centers
of the potatoes are cooked the outside
won't be falling apart and when you're
cooking potatoes always cook extra so
there's leftovers they're fantastic to
have on hand for making my delicious
gnocchi and potato rosters or a classic
bubbling squeak
right now it's all about stress-free
cooking
cooking dishes in advance is a brilliant
way of taking the stress out of cooking
at home and many dishes just get better
and better with time
[Music]
first up
amazing sticky pork ribs one of the
secrets to Great cooking is patience
leaving dishes to marinade for one or
two days helps to develop the flavor in
your food and the end result so much
more delicious it's a method I use in
the restaurants all the time
first off get your roasting tray put the
tray on the gas pork ribs six percent
meat and 35 40 fat give them a really
good season so
and pepper nice thing about this cut
they stay incredibly moist when they're
on the bone and the longer you cook them
the more delicious they become just push
all that seasoning in to the pork olive
oil in
make sure that tray is nice and hot
and I really want that nice sort of
caramelization taking place on the pork
that's the nice thing about starting it
on top of the stove use your roasting
tray get them colored and then in the
oven putting the ribs straight in the
oven
you don't get the color it looks sort of
boiled as opposed to a nice caramelized
rib Ginger
you can't beat fresh ginger with sticky
pork ribs
place it down nice and firmly and slice
the thinner you slice the ginger
the more fragrant the ribs
garlic
[Music]
and it's really important before you add
anything those ribs make sure you've got
the color and the ribs first don't rush
it
turn them over that's what I want
a nice crispy color
as they sort of raise in the oven all
that color just turns into the most
amazing flavor braisin is just a chef's
term for cooking something slowly in
liquid
right ginger and garlic in spread it
around on all those ribs to sort of
roast the ginger and the garlic chili
flakes chili flakes in next Szechuan
pepper citrusy vibrant peppercorns
incredible in
next star anise that gives it a really
nice sort of aniseedy flavor almost like
you're roasting the ribs in fennel then
now we've got the heat got the spice I
want to sweeten things up a little bit
some fresh honey
glazes the pork beautifully counteracts
against all that Spice in there but look
what's happening color on the ribs is
extraordinary it's like a really nice
chili sweet caramel now soy sauce brings
that little bit of sort of saltiness to
it really generous with the soy sauce
Japanese vinegar two tablespoons of
vinegar in rice wine
gives it that nice sort of tartness to
the ribs if you can't find rice wine a
dry sherry is a great substitute
300 mil
that takes out the heat for that
Szechuan pepper those dry chili flakes
make sure they're all laid down like a
nice tight box of matches bring that up
to the boil
cooking is all about learning to develop
your own likes and dislikes so always
keep tasting to make sure you're happy
with a combination of flavors
[Music]
it's lacking a little touch of vinegar
I want that sharpness now I think what's
going on the tartness the heat the
caramel the color on the ribs is amazing
I want a bit of a sort of oniony flavor
we've got some spring onions in
whilst these ribs are in the oven the
spring onions will sort of puree they
give a sharpness to the final taste of
that pork
in with my spring onions
and with my stock
400 mL of stock
this is just a simple chicken stock the
stock just sits underneath the ribs it
absorbs into the rib and the top of the
rib glazes underneath the rib that gets
crispy and Rich and that's what makes
the ribs nice and moist really important
into the oven
um
[Music]
cook at 180 for 30 minutes
then turn the ribs over and cook for a
further 30 minutes
[Music]
now
wow they smell incredible
each side has got that really nice
crispy roasted Edge becomes sticky and
chewy and sweet sour the fats
disappeared and the pork just melts in
your mouth I want to take them to the
next level gas back on now
shake the tray
and this is the sort of the way that we
finish them in the restaurant but every
minute
they glaze in that tray they just get to
taste better and better
now look at them
I'm so happy with those
ribs done absolutely delicious now but
if you want you can put them in the
fridge and the flavor will keep
developing then just reheat them when
you want to serve
so
Pink's rib has a nice slice of Ginger on
there
[Music]
wow look at that
delicious sticky ribs
with an amazing marinade
to make my food the tastiest it can be I
always start with the best ingredients I
can find and the secret to getting the
best is simple
knowledge is crucial the more you know
about where your ingredients come from
and how they produce the better so ask
lots of questions and learn
when it comes to buying pork you can't
do any better than ask a butcher and
award-winning Master butcher Danny
lidgate knows everything about the pig
from Trotter to tail this family have
been in the meat business for 150 years
so this man really is on the money
in comparison with other meats pork's
really good value you get some really
good cuts at really reasonable prices
and you can use everything from the tip
of the Trotter down to the cheek we can
see here we've got the leg the leg is
about this region
really lean really good for things like
gammons and hams coming down from the
leg we've got the loin and that's where
the pork chops come from if you take the
bones out you can bone and roll it and
you end up with a really nice easy to
cook cylinder of meat really easy to
carve carve like a loaf of breads
coming away from the loin we've got the
belly and you can see where belly is
made up of fatty parts and Meaty Parts
don't be scared of the amount of fat
that's on it you need that fat to give
give the flavors coming through also
make sure you can possibly buy it with
the skin on the skin will Crispen up
nicely give you good crackling also add
flavor into the fat
lower down from the bellies we've got
the shoulders
really the shoulders are a great meet
they're slightly fattier than the rest
of the animal you can see with this pork
shoulder the amount of marbling you're
getting the muscles the interior
marbling make sure you look for the
marbling it's essential for the flavor
and it's going to make a really good
eating experience
with a pig there really is nothing to
waste the trusses even a really good
flavor because they're gelatinous
qualities and the meat can be really
really flavoursome also there's pigs
chicks which obviously require a little
bit more cooking because of the use they
get but the flavors you're only going to
get are going to be completely different
to any other part of a pig
pork is an incredibly versatile meat
they say the only part you can't eat is
the Oink
here's my guide to getting the best out
of familiar cuts
smoked or unsmoked bacon it's not just
for breakfast it's brilliant
transforming salads gives a real depth
of flavor to stews and is delicious in
quick and easy pasta dishes
the leg joint best known for ham also
makes an inexpensive delicious Sunday
roast and is great served with peas
pudding
[Music]
tenderloin fillet incredibly lean
healthy and fast to cook you can stuff
it cut it into scallops or strips that
are perfect for Asian stir fries
[Music]
calm kitchen is an efficient and
effective kitchen the less stressed you
are the better the foods you'll produce
so whenever you can get ahead with your
cooking here are three of my favorite
recipes they've been made beforehand and
whose flavor improves over time
foreign
Lamb with sweet potato and raisin
[Music]
this super simple hassle-free recipe is
cooked all in one pot start by Browning
chunks of lamb in hot olive oil
color and remove
then fried onions
season
add chopped garlic ground ginger and
coriander
a teaspoon of whole cumin seeds
paprika and fennel seeds
[Music]
a cinnamon stick bay leaf and delicate
strands of saffron then fry to release
all the aromatic flavors next add tomato
puree
chunks and sweet potato and the juicy
Brown lamb
for a sweet note add plump raisins then
cover with stock and simply leave to
simmer for a couple of hours
delicious eaten straight away but over
time the flavors will develop and
improve
[Music]
when you're ready to serve simply finish
with fresh parsley
minimal preparation and ready when you
want it fantastic Moroccan Lamb with
sweet potato and raisin
my next super simple dish that just gets
better and better with time is chili
chicken with ginger and coriander
[Music]
start by chopping chicken thighs into
pieces now on with the marinade
chopped garlic
Ginger
red chili
and lemon juice
in a pan toast coriander and cumin seeds
to release their flavors grind and add
to the chicken
[Music]
then pour over plain yogurt add turmeric
and seasoning
mix and lead to marinade from two hours
to overnight next fry chopped onions in
olive oil
then add chopped garlic and ginger
ground coriander garam masala
and turmeric
tomato puree and butter
next add the marinated chicken and all
the remaining marinade and cook until
tender finally top with coriander
marinated for flavor and cooked in 20
minutes chili chicken with ginger and
coriander a simple stress-free Wonder
foreign
having a delicious sauce on hand to
serve with simply cooked fish or meat is
a brilliant stress Buster my final
recipe is sweet pepper sauce with
grilled prawns
for the sauce in hot olive oil if I
chopped garlic and diced bread
[Music]
then put them in a blender
add chopped tomatoes
blister the skin of red peppers under a
Hot Grill intensifying the flavor
leave to cool then they're easy to peel
chop and add Blitz
add smoked paprika chili flakes and
roughly chopped almonds
squeeze of lemon and a dash of Sherry
vinegar season Blitz again and add olive
oil
this sauce keeps really well in the
fridge and will intensify in flavor
I love it with simple King prawns just
add olive oil and griddle for two
minutes on each side
[Music]
sweet pepper sauce with grilled prawns
Simply Delicious
foreign
Advance ready when you want them three
stunning simple recipes that take the
stress out of the kitchen beautiful
[Music]
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stay your life on I'll be
showing you an amazing spicy Chutney
that's brilliant for transforming the
simplest of suppers
they don't actually smell much but the
flavor they give off is extraordinary
but first five more of my 100 tips to
make your home cooking easier kicking
off with how to skin and debone a fish
the hassle-free way
this is basically a filleted side of
salmon it's been taken off the bone and
now
skin off
pick up your knife a really nice broad
flexible
filleting knife
a little sharpen lift up
base of the towel and then just Nick a
little bit of the end there twist the
knife almost as if it's horizontally
underneath the salmon cool the skin and
you slice
the salmon underneath and let the knife
do the work now get your skin
flip it back over
check you're not leaving too much salmon
on top of the skin pull it back
and nice and slowly get the skin wrap
around your fingers pull the salmon
towards you and then just all the way
through
lay that down
one nicely skinned salmon just like a
perfect snake skin so
[Music]
get your knife and just run the Knife
Down
and then with a pair of tweezers these
are fish tweezers but you can use normal
tweezers
look for the head up
and Pull and with the skin being removed
from underneath the salmon
the pin Bones come out a lot easier
the pinballs only go to just basically
halfway
along the fillet
one nice fillet of salmon beautiful
[Music]
there's still plenty of flavor in the
trimmings from Affiliated fish my tip is
don't waste those fish bones add to
water wine a bay leaf and some chopped
veg to make a simple but versatile fish
stock at home the perfect base for a
delicious fish soup
a great tip for intensely flavored
stress-free veg is to steam them in
their own juices simply add to a pan
with a knob of butter and seasoning then
cook on a low heat with a lid on to lock
in the moisture
for crispy roast potatoes you can depend
on my tip is to parball them leave them
to steam dry then sprinkle them with
semolina or flour and give them a good
roughing up this ensures they go really
crispy in the oven
a great tip for Browning meat or fish is
to dry it with kitchen roll before you
cook it then you'll get a much better
color too much moisture makes the meat
steam instead of sear and you'll lose
that rich brown crust like the one I got
on those sticky pork ribs
[Music]
another secret to taking the stress out
of cooking is to anticipate the really
busy times when you'll need things to
hand that are already made
my next recipe can be kept on tap in the
fridge for weeks on end and is
guaranteed to liven up any quick meal
spicy chutney
with Chutney standing by in the fridge
you can always add that special little
touch to a simple supper prove that
thinking ahead always pays off
pan on to start toasting those spices
keep the pan nice and low cumin very
aromatic very fragrant and it's almost
like a light spice
next nice little coriander seeds
coriandering now you're going to get a
bit of heat in the Chutney mustard seeds
well smaller than coriander seeds but so
much more powerful mustard seeds in
now Curry leaves they don't actually
smell much dry but the flavor they give
off is extraordinary Curly's in
really important not to burn them
otherwise you'll
have that bitter taste across the
Chutney keep the gas nice and low the
secret is sort of toastable so it
releases that oil and tensifies the
spice a touch of salt
and then a couple of small powerful
chilies keep them whole no one's going
to eat them but it gives that real nice
burst of heat
now let them toast gently there we're
not going to chop the onion we're going
to grate it
why
because it sort of breaks down to really
nice puree in the Chutney when you're
grate it hold the root in the palm of
your hand and just push
nice long straight
I want those nice long shards
look I've almost got a nice sort of
onion puree but it's nice and clear
touch a volleyball
spices nicely toasted onions in
[Music]
three nice cloves of garlic nicely
crushed them
lay it nice and flat and just slice the
garlic
nice thin slices
garlic in
taking your time to get the owners
caramelized beautifully will really reap
rewards in the long run
Tamarind paste and sugar in with the
sugar first three nice tablespoons of
sugar
that will give really nice syrup effect
a sort of nice rich syrupy texture to
the chutney
Tamarind paste
you can get Tamarind paste in most delis
and the big supermarkets
it's really nice thickening Asian but it
gives that tartness the Chutney and it's
sort of Rich sugary spicy
[Music]
next in with my coconut add four nice
tablespoons that will give a nice body a
really nice texture to the Chutney cool
back coconut out and now and the carrot
grated
the carrot just gives the Chutney a
really nice sort of punch
but also helps to sort of cool down the
spice
carrots in
the water comes out of the carrot
flavors the Chutney beautifully but
gives that nice sort of vibrant bright
color to it as well
and grating it almost sort of it Cooks
instantly but I want a bit of texture
through here turn down the gas and just
let that simmer for five minutes
if the cars are that moist and juicy
then put a couple of tablespoons of
water in there to help it along
now just cook that out for five minutes
just so those carrots start going nice
and soft don't overcook them you want
that nice texture in there slightly
spicy slightly sweet gas off
keep those chilies in there for that
it's beautiful it's nice and gooey
delicious and
ready to go in his jar AS that sits in
the fridge
which gets better and better and better
I love to eat this chutney with cold
meats or even cold fish but with ham
it's amazing
it's a really nice way of livening up
the ham
just sort of roll it up
get a nice spoon of Chutney I mean it
looks fantastic Chuck me onto the plate
and serve and that is a nice little
gem in the fridge that is worth prepping
in advance for
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stay your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking